-Here we have Octavia Spencer
and Melissa McCarthy.
I know you guys are best
friends and so we thought
we'd do a fun game, almost
like a best friends challenge,
just to see how close
you guys are.
I mean, Octavia,
you guys are close, correct?
-Of course.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. All right,
and so here's the way it works.
It's called "The BFF Showdown."
-Okay.
-I'm going to quiz you to
determine which of you
knows the most about
the other one.
-Ooh.
-We got this.
-All right?
You think you got this?
All right, here we go.
If you get a question right,
you get a point.
Okay, here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
Melissa,
the first question is for you.
-Okay!
-Where did Octavia
go to college?
-Uh...
You know what? I don't think
she went to school.
-I absolutely did go to school.
-Yeah, okay.
I'm getting, like,
probably like
a Ft. Lauderdale University
kind of feel.
-Um...
-Lauderdale?
-Uh, no.
It's an easy one, Melissa.
Auburn! Auburn!
[ Buzzer ]
I went to Auburn.
-In Lauderdale?
-Uh, okay. Let's just --
Octavia, this one's easy.
Ready, Octavia?
-Mm-hmm.
-Is Melissa married?
-[ Chuckles ]
Pass.
-That was
a pretty easy one there.
I mean, you want to
pass on that one?
-You're gonna pass?
-I think I'm going to pass.
-What do you mean, like, Ben?
Ben.
Well, he's not my cousin.
-All right, all right.
Let's just --
Right now it's 0-0,
so anyone can still win.
-Okay, this is just a fluke.
-So we'll get rid
of that round one.
Now, this will be
the new round one.
Okay, we'll start
and we'll edit that out.
It's -- here we go. Melissa.
-Yes?
-What is Octavia's last name?
♪♪
I know, it's easy.
[ Chuckles ]
-You know what? It's --
I just don't say it.
You know,
you don't usually say --
It's -- Man, it's like on
the tip of my --
It rhymes with her
first name, I think.
It's not Octavia, isn't it?
[ Buzzer ]
-Octavia Octavia?
Melissa?
-Maybe I'm thinking
of your middle name.
-No, no. It's -- It's --
It doesn't rhyme.
-Wow.
-No rhyming.
Can we edit all that out
and, like, let this be
the first question?
-Octavia Boctavia.
Octavia Boctavia.
-I think that you would know
your best friend's last name,
wouldn't you? I mean --
-Well, I mean, she's right,
you never say it.
[ Laughter ]
You just never say it.
-Nobody -- If you're friends,
you don't say
the other person's last name.
That'd be so creepy.
I don't curtsy to her either.
-This next one -- Here we go.
Super easy.
Octavia, what does Melissa
look like?
Just a hint --
You can see her on Zoom now.
♪♪
-Let's look now.
-Okay, um...
-One of these boxes
on the screen...
-She's wearing green.
-...is Melissa.
[ Buzzer ]
What's that?
-She's wearing green.
-No, you're wearing green.
-I'm not wearing Green.
Are you looking at yourself?
-Oh.
Well, I guess that is me, huh?
-Uh, okay.
Let's go to the --
cut to the last question.
Okay, this one is worth
a million points.
Usually when we play the game,
it gets harder as we goes on,
but this one I'm going to
make this really easy. Ready?
-It started hard.
You started hard.
-Yeah.
-All right, here we go.
This one's very easy.
A million points.
Whoever gets this wins.
Either one of you guys say one
thing about the other person.
♪♪
-See, Jimmy --
-Here's the thing, no one --
you guys have just been silent.
It is -- anyone says anything,
I'll give you a million points
about the other person.
-I just -- You know what?
We just need to be transparent.
We don't really like --
we don't really hang out
in real life.
No, we're Hollywood friends.
You know, like, when the camera
stops, we stop.
-Wow. Okay, I get it.
I'm sorry. Wow.
-I've never actually
seen her in person.
-Really?
-You know, how you kind of,
it's like, whenever you hire,
you know, the two little,
the two little girls
that play your daughter.
-No, I didn't hire those girls.
That's my actual daughters.
They're my kids.
-That sweet woman you got
playing your wife, I mean,
I really love her.
You guys have good chemistry.
-She is good.
-Yeah.
-She's really good.
-She is my wife.
-Almost convinced me.
You almost convinced me.
-Yeah.
-She is my wife.
-"My kids are really my kids."
[ Laughter ]
-Me, too.
-Okay. Well, we'll be right back
with non-friends Octavia Spencer
and Melissa McCarthy.
When we come back,
more "Tonight Show, everybody."
-Can I use your kids?
I want to shoot something,
and I need a couple kids
to play my kids.
-No, they're not actors, though.
That's -- they're just
actual just kids.
-It's okay.
I'll call their agents.
It's fine.
-They don't have agents.